vous avez une grande entreprise
vous pouvez justement demandé à ce que
les plus faibles soient leers un peu
plus remonté et une baisse un peu des
plus grands salaires ça s'appelle ça
s'appelle du partage voilà il ya une
enveloppe données pour les salaires et
faire en sorte que cette enveloppe soit
mieux répartie entre les plus bas
salaires et les plus hauts salaires et
la deuxième chose c'est évidemment
d'augmenter le smic et et là je voudrais
dire quand même qu'il ya un effet
d'annonce qui est totalement qui est un
mensonge de la part du gouvernement
quand tu nous dis qu'ils aient un coup
de pouce sur le smic il ya aucun coup de
pouce sur le smic le la hausse de 2% qui
vient d'être décidé n'est qu'une
compensation de l'inflation donc la
perte du pouvoir d'achat de la monnaie 2
2% donc c'est une hausse automatique
néo-pop du travail qui n'a rien à voir
avec un coup de pouce et qui n'est donc
pas une amélioration du pouvoir d'achat
puisque puisque ça ne fait que compenser
l'inflation donc y'a aucun n'y a aucun
coup de pouce sur le pouvoir d'achat
alors que les factures de d'électricité
de gaz d'essence ont explosé son avec
des hausses de 10 à 15 % depuis un an
alors que les loyers continuent à
augmenter donc il ya un vrai problème
aujourd'hui de 2 voilà il faut vraiment
haussé le smic est bien au dessus de
l'inflation donc moi je pense qu'on
devrait aujourd'hui m le smic à
plusieurs centaines d'euros au-dessus de
ce qu'il est je rappelle qu'à une
enquête je vais finir là-dessus de
l'adresse donc du gouvernement faire du
ministère qui indique que les français
estiment qu'en moyenne un revenu décent
c'est 1750 euros net où vivent décemment
c'est ce que considère les français de
manière générale il faut 1750 euros pour
vivre décemment or le smic je le
rappelle est à 1250 et à tous ceux qui
nous écoutent je pense que ceux qui sont
au smic le seul s'en rendre compte en
premier lieu peut être que pour nous
c'est qu'ils veulent qui gagnons 2000
plus de 2000 euros est beaucoup plus
serein sans doute sur ce plateau c'est
compliqué à à entrevoir mais 1250 euros
r c'est une galère immense pour vivre a
en particulier quand harry famille et
c'est donc ça n'est pas décent pour
vivre donc c'est une question de justice
sociale et de dignité de dignité de vie
1250 euros non ça n'est pas suffisant
pour vivre décemment pour vivre de son
travail
[Musique]